separatist Rebels from the West Papua
National Liberation Army released images
of New Zealand pilot Philip Mertens the
group kidnapped him last Tuesday after
he landed his plane in Papa's remote
province of dugar his five passengers
were released Madden's aircraft which
belongs to an Indonesian Aviation
company was satellite the Indonesian
police are now scouring the remote area
where he was taken hostage Papua and
police are working with the New Zealand
authorities in a bid to negotiate his
safe release
military and police are ready we will
not back down whoever they are but the
safety of a human being is more
important that's the highest low so his
safety is our priority Papa declared
independence in 1961 but Indonesia took
control two years later the independence
Fighters are the armed Wing at the free
Papa movement and are vowed to fight
until their territory gains freedom from
Indonesia violence in this region
around the secessionist the independence
movement has been long-standing
um but we have seen an uptick in it in
the last 18 months or so
locals anticipating further violence are
now being evacuated from the area where
Mertens was abductant Sarah Clarke Al
Jazeera